I don't think it makes a difference if
you're in birth control or not in terms
of how promiscuous you are I think that
attraction can ebb and flow especially
when you're very stressed so I think
your actions speak louder than words so
if you do it then you think it I
actually I think divorce should be
illegal once it's a mistake the second
time's always a choice I forgotten that
that's what I grew up with settling
implies that like you somehow don't
deserve what you get I think you always
deserve what you get all of us here
though are speaking from a point of
privilege where we have a choice like we
have a choice everyone here has a job we
end a living we're fine there are a lot
of people coerced into corn there are a
lot of people that find themselves
trapped in it I think that it's unfair
to say that those people I think it's
perfectly Fair because men are in the
same situation and they don't have an
out they just go to McDonald's it's not
if the women don't want to go to
McDonald's that they choose to do they
tend to join the Army but yeah
joining the Army is better than doing
that yeah like but that's the point
women women we have a choice and so if
they make the selfish Choice it's it's I
think we can assume they're more selfish
I mean women are trafficked every day
and then end up in corn and then we're
not talking about women that are
trafficking I think we're talking about
we're talking about women we're talking
about women but like you keep going to
an exception and not the rule we're
talking about women that choose to do
corn I'm not I'm not talking about women
that work
yeah so do you think women that have
done that in their past should
not have the privilege of having
children no I think
it's hard I think everyone should
everyone should have kids yeah everyone
should have the choice but you can't
take away the accountability of knowing
that that action was selfish and that
you have to take accountability for what
your kids are could go through and
you've got to take responsibility for
that and at one point in your life you
might have to apologize for that and I
think that's where women don't that's
what women don't do it's like no but
they shouldn't be going through this
because of xyvid and they shouldn't yeah
that's just life it's like I shouldn't
have to always have to think about
locking my doors and locking my windows
if I leave my house but I have to be why
because I might not come back to no
you're not I'm going to answer your
question I think that women that have
done of or corn should be able to have
children if they want however I think
that men should not get them pregnant
yeah why would I tell a guy to pick her
when you could pick someone that doesn't
do it like would you want your brother
to pick someone that did corn or oaf or
your son no no
no no no
someone will always do it though so
that'll yeah yeah
and also too that that maybe comes from
the part that if you do corn then you're
like like you're written off as a woman
that's what you know like it's you know
it's like like people like what they
like and I just think that if that's the
path that you had to take whether it was
your choice or not then there's there
just has to be some accountability when
you do have kids and be like okay this
was me and can I just say when you said
certain choice I think you know when it
even comes to men that say you know you
don't want to work in McDonald's you
don't want a normal job you gotta and do
whatever it is you want to do most of
these things normally stem from which is
you want more money to do more things
that are actually not substantial
they're not things that you need they're
things that you want so ultimately that
choice isn't coming from a place of need
it's coming from a place of one you
don't want to work in McDonald's because
you don't want to wear Primark you don't
want to work in McDonald's because you
don't want to always have to eat let's
say corned beef and rice you want to be
going fat crab and you want to be doing
STK like what what is the reasons for
you making these choices is it for a
reasonable sacrifice or is it because
it's just selfish again for the for the
reasons of your own well-being to be
heightened most people in corn aren't
earning big money though that's a small
percentage of people that are earning
big bucks do people go into corn to make
little money is that their intention
nobody goes into any job to make little
money okay so it's still her point is
still the same you do it for quick money
[Music]
but people go into just because just
because you're bad at it like you're
still waiting for the same attention
I'll be so embarrassed if I started an
elephant but nobody bought it like do
you think people are going to start a
lying to make you know but boy guys
don't go to start a line or do certain
things to be making the same wage yeah
as a man that's only 30k I think from a
guy point of view as I said like I don't
think it writes you off as a woman as
you said there's always going to be men
that do go for go for that especially if
they think the girl is beautiful and
everything like that they'll still go
there but I think it's just I think
where it only just winds me up is you
know like Mia Khalifa for example
goes into corn
makes loads of money does really well
besides it's not for her and then it's
like well
no one should be judging me for what
I've done and that's just the world that
we live in she didn't make loads of
money that's why she's annoyed
no she still did do very well no there's
a number one she was the number one yeah
and she didn't get the money for it she
got a small pay for what she did
initially this is the whole thing that's
why she's on social media speaking out
against how much did she make I think it
was like ten thousand pounds it's more
than that no I'm pretty sure it was but
and then she said the production company
took everything else because that was
that was like the first Tick Tock I saw
from her was her talking about how like
she was taken advantage of
taking advantage oh come on she was not
taken advantage of I mean she's a very
young girl and she did some extremely
regrets she was like what 18.
I don't know probably my in my first job
at a uni I took a job very very silly
because it was very it's quite near my
home it was like a recruitment job for
like 16 500 pounds I could sit there and
say that I was taken advantage of no I
was just silly I made a very stupid and
dumb choice and it is what it is I
learned from it like common we all have
to be accountable for our choices I
can't just say oh because she was a
young girl come on I think you're
underestimating how manipulative these
industries are but you should get into
it she chose to get into it she wanted
to make money she made money she's upset
about the amount she made cool but she
wanted to make that money anyway so
regardless whether she made 20 pounds or
100K like and even and even if you just
saw the stats there as well even if she
made ten thousand which I know it was
more than that but let's say it was ten
thousand that's a lot of money for a
girl that age literally I'm not saying
that she didn't get ripped off by the
production company I agree with you on
that but that's still a substantial
amount of money I don't think that's a
lot of money for for what you're doing
and the fact that you then can't go back
and it's the same with like um Lana
Rhodes that's another one that speaks
out constantly about how she was coerced
into doing more and more and more and
she's is constantly told by these
production companies we've done it now
you can't get back you don't know you
can't go back but do you see the
tendency these stories it's all time she
was meant to drink her own sick she
chose to drink her own she like why do
we say coerced when it's a choice you
chose something this is the consequence
nobody's gonna respect you ever and why
did the crazy thing is these corn Stars
they still use their corn names if
you're so ashamed why do you still have
your core name go back to your legal
name that's the only way that she can
make money now is by influencing
essentially she has so she still makes
money off her name
McDonald's is hiring she could go to
McDonald's she just wants the lifestyle
and the attention or she could change
make money off of changing a narrative
literally
that's exactly what she's not because
she's still using her name exactly and
she knows that people are still going to
look for her under her name for that
reason because it makes our money it's a
continuation of what that gave her the
popularity and she's now using it to to
get the income that she now feels that
she deserves basically I think she is
totally entitled to that she's her own
personality now and her whole thing is
speaking out against the corn industry
but the reason why she's using that name
is because it's like
it's funny when your parents talk to you
and things come back to you it's like
you know that's what I say sometimes do
the best things that you want to be and
be who you want to be while you're young
because ultimately the reason why
they're still using these corn star
names is because they're on borrowed
time now they wasted all this time if
you know if you notice the bottom line
in all these situations people are angry
because this is time time is the
currency you can never get back I mean I
think it's just back to accountability
like women don't want to take
accountability for anything yeah like
she I mean I would respect it more
sorry I would respect it more if she
doesn't use words like I was coerced
like and she just owned it like I did it
it was stupid I'm moving on yeah and
changed her name I just can't how much
can you regret it if you have the same
name like if if that was me and I was so
ashamed I wouldn't want him anything to
do with it I wouldn't want anyone to
associate that name with me yeah I think
he's Devil's Advocate again I just
believe that they're using these names
like he said they're not taking
accountability one but two because they
feel like they're on borrowed time so
they're trying to find this minimal
thing to help them
still reap the benefit of that time that
they wasted do you see what I mean yeah
I disagree
I feel like it's almost like another
bailout for women's bad decisions so you
can go on like a hoe apology tour it's
like you can do that and then go back
and make more money apologizing for it
it's like it's like a system yeah that
needs to be broken to be honest do you
think that birth control weight makes
women more sleepy
[Laughter]
birth control was banned would you be
more would you be less promiscuous like
would you sleep around less would you be
more careful with who you slept with I
mean I still don't look around I'm not
saying you do I'm just like would you be
more careful birth control okay outside
of
Doms it doesn't
it's not like you're blocking yourself
from SD you know like so whether you're
on birth control or not you're still at
risk of those things so I don't think it
makes a difference if you're in birth
control or not in terms of how
promiscuous you are because it's not
protecting you against diseases and so
you're just basically it's just
protecting you from pregnancy that's the
only thing so you're still at high risk
for all the things that are out there so
to use birth control as an excuse to be
promiscuous that's his excuse so I'm
just wondering if you think you so you
think a girl that's promiscuous is going
to be equally as promiscuous with or
without birth control absolutely yeah
but I think being promiscuous with the
partner I think that would change for me
like I'd be a lot more careful with my
boyfriend to say then if birth control
was not permitted in the UK I think I'd
have to be more careful with my
boyfriend but it wouldn't make me not
sleep her right that's that's just not
my type of drip would you get married
like quicker if birth control was banned
I think I think yeah I think I think I'd
probably I feel like you'd I feel like
taking away birth control would allow
people to settle quicker and settle for
less quicker if that makes sense so I
feel like it would take away that option
of being able to make more of a choice
because I think
yeah you just you yeah it just changes
everything I think not being because I
think back in the day when people you
did used to fall pregnant at 16 and
stuff when I speak to my parents and
people that are around their age group
literally everyone would know if you
went to the clinic to get something like
it's not like now where you can go there
it's confidential and they would make it
work they'd have shotgun weddings the
dad would get yeah you're marrying my
daughter like my mom would say she could
never go down to the local Clinic
without her mom my mom said there was
two girls in her high school class that
got pregnant they're both still married
to the guy okay they just they just made
it worse
um condoms when you say birth control do
you mean everything or do you mean just
like pills I meant pills because I mean
from my personal experience when I
between the ages of 21 and now 25 I
didn't take birth control and I was
still like having sex sometimes with
guys that I dated I start I went back on
birth control when I went into a
long-term relationship where I felt like
um I know this person doesn't have
anything I know that like I'm not taking
any risks I still had sex before I still
you would just use condoms before I just
use condoms yeah because I don't want
any diseases is it because it was less
frequent because you weren't dating
someone is that why you chose to go on
birth control it was I think there's a
period of time if I was dating for
someone for like three or more months at
that point I'd be like oh maybe we
should think about this now
um as a more like viable option for us
um but I had sex I had one night stands
I still slept with people you know and
you take a risk when you do that but
[Laughter]
anyone here think birth control makes
you anyone
Noah I do I do yeah do you take it no I
don't take it I've ever taken it
um not really no oh that's a yes that's
not really very very short like six
months why did you stomp
um I stopped because I just
wash your contraception by the way but
you took for six months uh it was an IUD
oh okay yeah but I don't know I started
like dating a guy and then it was just
like how do I put it I just felt like I
felt like turning off your uh like your
I just felt like it was going to be bad
in the long term you know I mean like I
just felt like it like at some point it
would make me like something would
happen like I felt like there would be
side effects I didn't feel any side but
you didn't in the six months that you
took it you didn't feel any what side
effects were you worried about sorry I'm
like interviewing you know
um I just I was just nervous I wanted a
lot of care I want a lot of kids so I
was just nervous I couldn't have a lot
of kids it doesn't affect your fertility
though that's not what I like I don't
know about an IUD I don't know much
about I have to be honest I don't know
much about iuds themselves I know
they're very painful to put in I I just
felt like you just never know with that
type of stuff
so I I just I just felt like doctors
that are selling the stuff have an
incentive to lie to you yeah and I just
I I didn't I'm not a science person I'm
not going to pretend like I understood
it I just was like um I don't know
but I still stand on I do think birth
control makes you overall yeah
did you feel when you're on it
then no actually no but I think by and
large I think by and large it does I
think you're more likely to make crazy
decisions when you're on birth control
did you make any crazy decisions on
birth control no then what do you think
though
on it for a long period of time
so I think six months is a long time
it's long enough to see if you have any
side effects yeah but I was with the
same guy so it was like yeah but like
what about it makes you think that it it
makes women's like I just think when you
have a bailout of a bad decision you're
more likely to make it are you sure so I
think if you if you have a Fail-Safe for
making a bad decision you're more likely
to make it and I think I avoided a lot
of like bad decisions because I wasn't
on birth control most of my life
so you felt like making slushy decisions
but haven't because you're like I'm not
on birth control ever yeah sure
interesting like what like being at a
party and you're like oh I can see this
guy oh I'm not in birth control so I
won't like that kind of thing
um
I mean I don't really want to get like
it wasn't like it wasn't like a party or
anything it was just like I don't know
maybe someone I was dating like I'd just
have to like think about more what the
consequence would be you think you might
do it sooner yeah yeah okay yeah so but
if there's like a small window for you
to get pregnant
then effectively birth control doesn't
really have much say in terms of you
sleeping around really and truly because
if you can like you know there's all
these apps that you can have a look at
and I was just always nervous like I
just always like never wanted to be
pregnant like outside of marriage so I
was just always scared to be honest
because I mean women go on birth control
for different reasons of course we have
like for acne but in terms of some
people go on it because they don't want
to be pregnant or have that kind of
unexpected pregnancy but there's like
other reasons why they decide to go on
birth control whether it's I don't think
it's because they want to sleep around
well I mean I mean just like what else
is it for you mentioned earlier acne and
things like that yeah but I'm asking
around the room no one's on it for acne
some people I take it I know people that
take it to regulate them so you're
talking about exceptions and not the
rule I'm talking about the I think most
girls take birth control to not get
pregnant yeah that's what's for yeah
yeah and so I'm talking about the rule I
mean if we can if we have every
conversation we have to bring up the
exception like we're going to be talking
all day I'm talking about the rule
um I think I don't know I feel like
passing for me after hours on
contraception because that with my
boyfriend I don't want to feel like I've
got to be precautious in terms of having
a baby because like you said Pearl I I
don't want to have a child with someone
that I'm not going to spend the rest of
my life with so I was always paranoid
about having a baby by accident and
obviously I'm still very young so I'm
ovulating I'm it it's less likely for me
to not be pregnant I mean it's less
likely for me to
yeah not be pregnant and pregnant so for
me it's a situation where that's why I
was on contraception because I didn't
want any form of like oopsies no no I
didn't want that but I also feel like I
think I
Caribbean right it and I feel like here
there's this sort of thing where the
doctors are quick to recommend birth
control whereas I asked for it but like
here like I've got friends who were on
it from like 16 and I'm like that's a
crazy age because I think it was to kind
of
um help them with cramps but I'm like
cramps is like something you have like
probably five days out of the month so
why is it so much of a thing of an
agenda where the doctors are quick to
recommend it rather than it be your
choice when you feel like okay this is
you know I'm getting into adulthood this
is my decision rather than it being
recommended so that's why I think a lot
more people are on it because from a
young age it's just like it's the agenda
of the doctor to be like hey go on this
like my mom would have never dreamed of
like telling me at a young age to like
go on birth control it's just I always
told me not to yeah I just I just felt
like long term like there would be some
side effect from basically tricking your
body into thinking you're pregnant every
month for years I don't know what it is
I'm not a science person I don't know
yeah that was
did you know that if you look at the
divorce rate and the rate of women on
birth control they're like the same
what do you mean
let me let me find it I'm gonna send it
to King
Force rate
what is the lack of correlation or it
just happens to be the same as if like
married women are often on birth control
no default is it divorcement I mean yeah
so I'm gonna send this to King
um
do you mean like women on birth control
are getting more divorces
because if you look at it from a history
perspective the divorce Reform Act came
in 1969 which is when you could
basically get a divorce for no reason
and birth control became freely
available in 1974. oh you hold on so
those two things would obviously
correlate but that doesn't mean that
there's a correlation it just means that
those things happen at the same time you
could argue that
I think that you know I asked my grandma
my grandma is um very sick she like so
I've been asking her like life questions
lately
and I asked her because she was you know
around in the 70s when you know people
started getting divorced a lot like
you're right no fault divorce was
implemented and I asked her like why she
thought that
women like why why the like what changed
in relationships
my grandma said birth control
now again it might it might not be
related but look at this chart it's
actually kind of crazy
sorry to hear that by the way yeah same
as what I do oh yeah I know it's
okay she's she's like um like yeah she's
she's
um
she's been sick for a while so it's kind
of like
um
is that age on the left
no
King did you get it I sent it to you on
Insta
okay
I think the correlation between that
could be back to when they say that when
a woman sleeps with more than five
people those divorce rate tends to cheat
because she's she's she's in a habit of
just moving on when it gets tough or
moving on at that point so the
correlation would be that she's making
more choices to sleep with men because
she doesn't have to make she's got that
bailout that you're saying her body
count then goes up which means she's
less likely to stick around in a
situation that she's not used to dealing
with the point I was making though is
that like divorce divorce rules divorce
rates and birth control would obviously
go up at the same time because birth
control was made freely available on the
NHS in the 70s and divorce without any
reason was basically introduced in the
late 60s it would happen at the same
time is it just the same numbers or is
it I'm going to show you the chart it's
the
um
it should be like the first one on the
left that's on the screen do you see it
on the left yeah on the left top corner
is
is that to match your point of women
being more approached to us that's a
good thing that's what I mean okay but I
can understand in that point okay you're
you've recently divorced and like if you
want some of your besties you've got
seat belts on you're probably driving
more you know what I mean but with these
women on birth control before they got
divorced or after they got divorced I
think probably also are they like going
on birth control because they've had
their kids and now they can't deal with
their husband because they've had his
kids I don't know that is that is common
women do divorce men
um I've interviewed I've interviewed a
divorce attorney and that's what they
say they said they'll get the two kids
and then stop sleeping with the husband
and then divorce him yeah because if
he's not pulling his weight and they're
doing all the work with the kids they
wouldn't be attracted I sense like a
little bit of an anger towards men from
you a little bit no I love them and it
doesn't sound like it based on how
you're talking no I think because you're
like he's not pulling his weight why
doesn't he just fight for his kids like
you always kind of automatically take
the woman's side I think that you can
take down that chart they see it I would
argue that right now that that's just
the room I'm in that I feel the need to
to pull that but in general like no I
love men and like the men I know and the
circles I'm in are what is What is
marriage to you
um well when I get married that would be
like I want to get married and then I
want to have my babies and you know
that's what's that like what's the point
of marriage uh for me it would just be
making us one unit and that to me is
like my forever and we are now
financially connected with everything
connected we're gonna have each other's
children and we're gonna spend our lives
together okay so you do believe like
when you get married it's forever
yeah okay in an ideal world yeah okay so
do you believe that it's in in sickness
and in health for richer or for poorer
For Better or For Worse yes okay so then
not when the man isn't pulling his
weight no I
I what I was saying though is that like
she might not want to sleep with him
that doesn't mean she doesn't love him
and she wouldn't stay with him but she
may stop having sex with him if he's not
if so she uses sex as a way to control
him if he's not dead well she might not
be attracted to him why why is she not
attracted to him they
need is attracted to somebody who
doesn't like help them and like do you
believe in Duty what do you mean by that
like do you believe you have duties in a
marriage or do you believe you should
just do what you want what makes you
happy but are you implying that sex is a
duty I am do you do you believe that sex
is a duty sex is a really complicated
thing I'm a person with a really high
sex drive I can't imagine like not
having sex with my boyfriend every day
what would you do if your boyfriend
stopped having sex with you I would find
it really difficult which is why I
understand that there's so much nuances
topic so I feel like I do have like and
also women don't take rejection as well
as men do often in the bedroom
um but like I also understand that there
are situations in a marriage where you
may go through a dry spell because
you're busy because you're stressed
because you haven't had two children and
it's like physically impossible
I understand like if you have medical
issues but outside of medical issues
we're just talking normal why would you
not want to sleep with your husband
I think that attraction can ebb and flow
especially when you're very stressed
it's hard enough yeah it's hard for me
to speak on because I've not been in
that situation myself so I can only
speak on like based on my friends
experience and what they've told me of
like I don't want to sit with my husband
because I don't see him anymore and like
he's working all the time and you know
what I mean it's hard to for me to speak
from myself because I've never been in
that scenario do you think that men get
married thinking their wives will stop
sleeping with them no nobody gets
married because they're not going to
sleep with each other okay so don't you
think that's a bit unfair to men to like
they're already risking so much going
into marriage they're risking you
falsely accusing them of abuse they're
risking all their assets and now they
can't even get sex out of it I think
women get married wanting to have sex I
don't think anyone wants to not have sex
but whose choice is it typically to not
have sex the men or the women the woman
okay so it's the women not sleeping with
the man often I would say yeah that's
okay and you'd agree so would you agree
that that's unfair to men
no I don't think you're entitled to
somebody's body
but so you don't think sex is a duty
from wives to husbands not a duty no I
think I think it's a lovely thing that
you can share in I think intimacy is
very important in a relationship and I
think if sex stopped forever you might
get divorced over it I think intimacy is
incredibly important but do I think that
it's ever owed and do I think the
expectation of owing would make anyone
want it more no but not oh but like
shouldn't you want to do that yeah I do
want to like with my boyfriend but it's
hard to right but I'm saying like like
it's just like the way you're you're
speaking it's kind of like do whatever
you want in marriage like do what makes
you happy do do what you feel is right
but it's like if you want a long and
happy marriage how are you going to do
that if you're not sleeping with your
husband but if you're having sex when
you don't want to with your husband I
can't imagine that but it must be a
terrible feeling do you do you think
that sometimes in marriage you're gonna
have to do things you don't want to do
for the family sex is a very unpleasant
thing to do if you don't want to do you
can just play there what are you really
doing why would you get married though
if that's if that's an option
for you with that person I think it goes
back to when you ask why do you want to
get married I think I don't want to get
married to feel like a unit to want to
have kids with someone to want to love
someone I'm getting married because I
can't wait to enjoy that day with that
person just for us to enjoy it's like a
declaration of me showing you again why
I love you it just comes with a lot more
responsibility in terms of like you said
we come together as a unit financially
on paper but it shouldn't change the
status of your your love your
relationship you know I think when you
get with someone and you say to yourself
this is the guy that I want to marry you
have a duty to never stop trying if
you're at a point in a relationship
where you feel like you don't know if
you want to try with this person anymore
the option of getting married should
never be an option because you when you
get into a relationship that's why
relationships fail because people don't
understand that when love is true love
it becomes a thing of you're not selfish
and you you vow to without that marriage
you vow to always try when it's hard
when I'm in a mood when I'm on my period
when everything's heightened I still try
for that person and a marriage doesn't
Define that and I really hope you get
that but there is a million different
factors that recent relationships break
up and yeah as much as you try and also
I don't think in marriages
I think there's a million stupid factors
that marriages break up yeah yeah I
think yeah I really do I think that
women get divorced for a lot of stupid
reasons like what
um Financial I think is pretty dumb um
not being happy anymore I think that's
pretty dumb
um I think really anything outside of um
I'll give you infidelity like if he gets
another girl pregnant
I'm gonna give you that one you're so
generous yeah thank you I am so good
thank you
um I'm gonna say abuse there's one
um and honestly I don't even really
believe in divorce I believe in
separation you know and then you try to
work it out but I'll give you abuse I'll
give you abuse I'll give you that
um
trying to think that's really it abuse
nowadays someone came on my pod and said
you should get divorced for not doing
the dishes so you know
marriage has changed I guess
um
that's all I can think of those two
that's what I got can I ask a question
because she's about sex and Duty within
a marriage so do you think the piece of
paper that says I do the marriage
certificate gives is then lifelong
consent to have sex with me no matter
the situation I wanna I wanna I wanna do
one caveat it is not okay for him to
forcefully have sex with you ever okay
but I think I think one I don't see the
point of getting married if you believe
divorce is on the table for damn near
anything what's the point be in a
relationship don't get married like I I
just genuinely don't see the point I
don't think there's many people that get
into a marriage and stand there on that
day thinking oh I've got a way out and I
have many years you know but there's I
think your actions speak louder than
words so if you do it then you think it
you thought it at least once yeah
um so I'd like that caveat that's that's
not okay no no grape none of that none
of that but I think as a wife you should
have sex with your husband whenever he
wants pretty much no matter what his
behavior is or I don't think you should
use sex to control your husband I think
that's wrong so I think it's actually
trust you sex to control you
um why did two wrongs make a right are
we on the playground no yeah so so I
think a lot of women use sex to try to
control their husbands wrong wrong I
think that's mean men need sex and I
don't if you do that I don't feel bad if
you get cheated on I don't feel bad not
even a little bit and I feel like they
do that sometimes because they're
actually not strong enough to actually
stand up in a situation when they should
so they use other anomalies to get out
what has been swept under the mat rather
than facing that argument or facing what
he'd done that was wrong at that moment
at that time so if it doesn't like
cooking things like that that you stop
doing and things rather than being
direct and not being naive and then like
exert that in a whole like you said the
wrong way instead of the right way and
communicating I think that if you want
to get divorced for damn near anything
just don't get married like what's the
point of getting married like what's
then just just be in a relationship I
had someone I'm not gonna name names
Destiny say that say that you should get
divorced over chores oh go get that's
fine it's ridiculous that's fine if you
want to do that but what's then don't
get married marriage is supposed to be
for sick or for poor for better for
worse he did make it into quite a good
point you're right it is a stupid reason
but he did make it sound quite I
understand
he's gonna make it so good can I also
point out though that Destiny is
actually the only one married here
though
doesn't make him not marry yeah but like
am I gonna draw an experience space you
know I I had to have a video coming out
about this but I have an aunt you know
and she expressed that like her concern
was she couldn't stay
um like she was so frustrated with her
husband right and she she was like he
was so messy I just couldn't deal with
it and she's been married like 20 years
and honestly she's one of the most
feminine women that I know like they're
like she's just one of those ants that
comes in you know and you just feel like
at home you know you know the aunt right
she's like the sweetest lady and she was
like yeah I was so mad but then I
thought every time I picked up my sock I
would just say I love you Jason I love
you romance I was her husband and her
son and she said she I had to change my
thinking and stop complaining and just
do it and think of it as doing something
that I love for them so like what's a
better mindset get divorced over chores
or learn how to learn how to love the
person because you're not perfect either
and that's the thing I was just lost the
word I now remember it that that love
she that moment she made a decision of
it not being egotistic love and actually
being true love because she's now not
trying to change a person or continue to
be frustrated she's accepting that
person for who they are and making that
work for her so if she has to tell
herself that every single time that
works for her some people might just
throw it and be like he could pick out
when he comes in that might work for
them but that's when love is not
egotistic and it's true
[Music]
um
I think there's any other topic I wanted
to cover
I think that's pretty much it you have
any questions guys any anything you want
to talk about
can I ask you another birth control
question
if it's not too nosy oh it might be a
little bit noisy but you don't have to
answer there's no pressure If you got
into a new long-term relationship now
would you go on birth control would you
consider it or would it just be
completely out of them no no I don't I
just I just want a lot of kids and I
just I don't want to do anything that
would like jeopardize that so and it may
not but I just don't I don't even want
to take that risk personally
um
I think back to switching topics the
marriage topic I feel like
also I feel like there's a lot of kids
having kids these days and that leads to
kind of unprofound like child neglect
and I think households because sometimes
it's not planned or people quite young
they when you're in a relationship
people don't understand you have to have
the patience to adopt that person as now
being a parent so as much as you was in
love with them as just you and them you
have to give room for that person to
change and accept them changes and
sometimes when you fight the changes
that frustration kicks in which then
breaks up a home and I feel like divorce
is a lot more just like I'm gonna go out
with you or marriages look like I'm
gonna go out with you and break up with
you as divorce now because I feel like
society and the way things have changed
from tradition has kind of changed the
morality around marriage and I think the
actual reasoning behind marriage has now
been shifted and it's now you take it as
you want it and there's certain things
in life that I feel like cannot be
changed it's meant to be the it's meant
to be and if you can't adopt that nature
then leave it alone
I agree with you I I think that a lot of
times
people look at marriage as like a
long-term relationship it's I don't I
actually I think divorce should be
illegal
illegal yeah except for I'll give you
I'll give you those too and if I think
of one or two more I'll add them but I
would make it a legal band band but why
because I just don't see the point like
what is the point of marriage like
marriage is supposed to be for for
better for worse in sickness and in
health for richer or for poorer like
that that's what marriage is supposed to
be so if you can get out then it's not
marriage that's my opinion on it um now
I don't want women getting abused long
term that's that's I'm not for that so
I'll let those women I'll let them out
but even just when you see like I've
known children who like obviously like
growing up with my friends I've had
friends of mine I've been like God I
wish my parents had got divorced growing
up because all they ever did was argue
it's not abusive they just don't get on
they just don't love each other they
just shouldn't have stayed together and
I and I hear that from kids but
oftentimes those kids turned out pretty
well yeah I was gonna say and so now
like would they really feel that way if
they only saw their father six days a
month is that a better outcome
it's hard to argue but because I wasn't
in that situation but I think for a lot
of people like I've heard people say a
lot like I wish my parents would divorce
because they would have been happy and
it would have been less traumatic to not
try and play the Wii and hear people
scream each other out it's a bit spoiled
I don't know in some situations because
I feel like don't get me wrong like
I feel like it's a bit spoiled because
you know nothing's perfect there's not a
perfect home there's not a perfect
family there's not a perfect person it's
not a perfect relationship it's about
never stopping trying so then parents
I'm grateful to my parents for never
stopping trying because I understand
what a man's duty is because my dad is
around my dad is an active role in my
life because if my mum pulled a plug or
my dad pulled the plug would I be as
confident would I know my duties also as
a woman because I can see my mum and the
way she is with my father and I think
that's why it's important back when you
said like you're so paranoid about when
you have children because I want my
children to have that and not because I
just want that for myself with my
partner is because I think it's a it's
part of that Foundation of them being
the best people that they can be and
that's why there is men and women
because we have roles to play in our
children's lives and I think people that
come from I'd say broken homes they
would agree that sometimes they go
through more traumatic things you know
they go through a lot more challenges
mentally sometimes even physically in
life than people that have come from a
whole household if that makes sense and
what's the better solution get divorced
or work it out figure out how to get
along like like in those cases the most
qualified person to answer this is just
a divorced woman yeah but every uh
relationship has its own unique set of
circumstances and I
um level everything you guys are saying
about like how you think these things
are going to go and stuff like that and
that's and that's great but life doesn't
always work out like that
I agree but um I also do agree with you
I do think a lot of people do rush into
marriage
um because obviously you see the amount
of people that you know that get
divorced like the percentage rate is so
high and a lot of the time I I've even
had the conversation I thought oh you
know I'm actually not that ass about you
know getting married I feel like a lot
of men are starting to come around to
that yeah and it gets shut down straight
away and I know you can say you know you
want your children to have the same last
name but then after that you know
even on a financial one if you are the
person that makes the majority of money
in the relationship I'm saying that's my
situation but
um yeah you are it's gonna be a struggle
and a lot of men just aren't as fuss
about it because they do take a lot more
risks if they are the person that's
earning more money like my mum and Dad's
been together
can't marry no what they've been trying
I think lockdown happened they were
meant to get married and then lockdown
happened and since then we're just
trying to work through things but I
think you know again I'm happy my mum
and dad didn't get married because that
is a memory I'd always have with God
willing I'd always have with them and
have of them you know but it showed me
that like you said like you going
through them things in a marriage is not
going to stop you like some again it's
wants and needs to like separating the
two you don't need to have your child
your child having the same last name as
you is not going to keep the family
together bro like that doesn't keep you
together that's that's a one it's not it
I wish I wish there was a second
marriage for the girls like me that
don't believe in divorce because it's
like as a guy why would you get married
like I can't think of one good reason
why would you do it but then that's
that's why there's prenups so if you're
a strong believer in not getting
divorced then you have those you can you
can put those things in place to you
know if you were to divorce between a
certain amount of years like you can
like you can format it to be something
that would actually
almost like kind of in a way threatened
for him not to divorce you
um so there's these Provisions but I I
grew up in a household where my parents
got divorced
um and I can remember I was like in high
school I think I was like one year
before the last year and I found out
from my mom seeing a friend and she was
like oh how's your husband she's like oh
we're divorced and it happened when I
went a summer away and I remember I was
like absolutely devastated but looking
at it now like it didn't affect me like
my dad is still in the picture
um and I think fantastic that my mom
kind of set that example because my dad
was cheating and it was it was so
consistent that I at one point was like
he used to pick me up from school and my
mom used to travel because of work and
he picked me up and this lady was in the
front seat and I'm a daddy's girl so I
used to be in the front seat of that he
did not and she was in the front seat of
the car and I had to go in the back so
that happened like 2 days in a row and
then my mom came back from traveling and
I was like Mom who's this woman that
keeps on having me sit in the back seat
and the look that she gave me I was like
oh I was young I was probably like seven
and I understood but then after that my
dad used to do stuff because my mom
asked for a divorce like it was he he
signed the papers and she wasn't nasty
about it but my mom is a smart woman in
that like our home is under my sister
and my my name so it has nothing to do
with like him trying to take the house
and stuff like that but I'm very
grateful that my mom made that decision
because it's kind of showed me how a man
should treat me like did you did she get
remarried no no do you think the outcome
is better for her being alone
um absolutely because you know what like
she she's still open to how old is she
oh she won't she would dare won't let me
tell you her age but 60s early early
okay okay
um so you think life at like 75 is gonna
be happier for her but with by herself
instead of with a husband my mom is so
happy at this age it's my dad who you
can't tell him and this is like early
this is probably
2000 and I think nine they got divorced
you can't tell him today that's not his
wife he will call and he'll be like
where's my wife and she'll be like we've
been divorced for years but for him
he's at that point that was his wife who
else who else what other what other man
has had more of an impact on her or will
well
but it really and really like well it
really is his wife I mean yeah she's got
he you know he's got two beautiful kids
and for her it's like well
she always said you will there will come
a day while you'll be on this side and
I'll be on this side with the girls and
you will
want to appreciate what you had and for
him he's well my dad's like what 67 he's
a couple of years older no he's turning
70 in December and my dad I can see that
he is very aware like his friends were
cheetahs as well they've passed on and
so now their wives are widows but he
understands how much at that age you
need a woman in your life because he's
getting that although he has girlfriends
that that's nothing to him he wants that
woman where he can grow old with and
he's lost that opportunity so I can
really see it affecting my dad that up
to this day he has heartache because you
know of the choices that he made but
he's still never stopped so yes when did
when did he start no that's that's
another thing when did he start
um because they got married before me
um
you know when did he start and when did
he get caught is probably two different
things but to have the audacity I'm
talking about like this woman attacked
my mom and my sister and he he was he
continued to be with her and you know
sometimes in the Caribbean we're like
okay she put a spell on him and stuff
like that but
we couldn't understand why he would
choose this woman that he just met over
his family you know and it happens but I
couldn't see that he is really really
facing yeah big time and I think I mean
that are doing corn it's the same thing
when you do certain things and make
certain decisions you do see that not to
say karma but because once it's a
mistake the second time's always a
choice because it's now conscious you
can't make a mistake twice so he's seen
the unfortunate consequences of that and
it goes back to again with women doing
corn it's just your kids will then the
consequence that comes with that as
children you're still affected and you
know what I will say as well with what
your story was men always realize
everything too late they always realize
because even my parents like my parents
they're not together anymore they're
divorced but the way my dad used to
treat my mom compared to how he treats
her now that he can't have access to her
the way he did before is so different
like I personally think that if you
treat her like how he does now like the
respect that he does have for her now
and the way he speaks about her like if
he treated her like that when they were
married and when we were all living in
the same house like everything would
have been so different and I asked him
today like like his opinion on their
marriage he says like if he knew
everything that he knows now like he
thinks that things would have gone so
different but obviously my mom is so out
of that space is she remarried no so why
doesn't she just work it out if he's
treating her right he's he's remarried
but he's still but I'm not gonna lie
like he's still like you know what I
mean but you see the outcome seem worse
for both of your moms to be honest I
mean it depends how you look at it I
think that being alone at an old age is
worth is is worse but my mom is so much
more happier now that she's free from
him like she feels like she has her own
say in her life she can work for herself
and she has her children like she's so
much happier when she feels like she
doesn't have the burden of someone else
she's about to turn 50 next year but
right now like she's the happiest I've
seen her I just wonder if that'll be the
same like I we're supposed to live to be
90. so you know 70 to 90 I think it's
pretty lonely when you're by yourself
but can I you know like for example well
kind of because
um my grandparents died a year within
each other so my grandfather passed away
and my grandmother passed away a year
literally a year after because of um
heartbreak you know but like my mom she
does not look her age compared okay yes
my dad's a bit older and he doesn't look
old as well but you won't take my mom
for a 60 year old like you put her early
50s and she's just so much happier like
she she's an independent woman anyway so
it's not like the divorce affected her
like lost assets and stuff like that no
but in terms of Happiness absolutely
she's like she she can live past 90 in
my opinion healthy well and I hope I
hope they genuinely are like I'm I'm
just on the outside looking in and it
just seems like a lot of times women
leave their husbands and think the grass
is greener on the other side and they
end up by themselves and if that's a
happy outcome for them you know so be it
it just on the outside looking and
doesn't seem like that I was gonna say
as well because I I know women that have
stuck through things
for their reasons whether it be their
kids keeping their family homes together
and like he said men kind of do see
things later on and you know that when
you said in a relationship with money a
guy wants someone that will be there for
him though that's I'm saying that's
wrong of course he's wrong I'm not I'm
not like permitting adultery but I'm
saying it's one of them ones where
through that time where he was making
bad decisions you stuck through that
with him and you would then reap that
benefit then benefits I know I know a
couple like that where the it was really
similar like the dad was messing around
like crazy yeah and um they worked it
out and like they were happier than ever
later literally and it's like now like
I'm not saying you know your parents are
great and that's great but I'd say women
that I have seen not not stick that at
all kind of just made not that they were
cheated on but just split up with men
had babies and not with them guys and
whatever now the women that did stick
that through seem a lot happier and a
lot more what I mean is a lot of stress
less stress-free like they're just like
example they don't have mortgages to
worry about their kids are doing their
own things they're confident they worry
about them so much and then the kids end
up having to take care of the mom when
she's by herself instead of the husband
yeah
um I was going to show you guys this
chart have you guys ever seen the sexual
market value chart can you zoom in on
that just slightly
slightly
so this is I zoom in more okay more can
you go more
oh we can't go anymore
um okay you guys
um is there any way could you click the
other one on the right that'll be bigger
could you click the site maybe and see
if that helps
can you zoom in on that
okay and clicked click that I agree
there you go
okay so this is the chart of basically
dating options based on age so you can't
see it because it's it's basically 23 is
a woman's Peak we're about 38 is a man's
Peak
and that's basically your value in the
marketplace based on how many options
you have to the opposite sex so you'll
see around
um can you put your mouse over where 35
is
okay
yeah so that's compared demand where
theirs goes up and so this is just
something that I see with older couples
when they do get divorced the men end up
getting remarried because they have more
of a leverage in the marketplace where
the women don't
yeah that explains why there's a lot
more yeah older guys dating like I've
got a lot of friends that are dating
that around my age 23 24 dating guys
that are like in their 30s and it's
working yeah
I prefer dating guys in their 30s
um and the because when women are over
the age of like I think it's 50 they
have a 25 like
I think there's I'm gonna butcher this
but it's basically like men under the
age of like 30 have a 25 chance of being
in a relationship and it flips after
like age 55 or 50. right
um see like from my mom she has the
options have happened someone in her
life but she just chooses not to because
I think she I think what she went
through with my dad was more than enough
like to start over and have those kind
of concerns okay would he be cheating I
think she's just like actually I Can Do
Bad All By Myself like you don't think
she'd prefer to be with a man she loves
and respects over being by herself like
if she could pick one of the two but
then it also goes back to like
and you know when we date we always
always have these kind of things okay is
he gonna be faithful what's his history
for her to stop that all over again for
her it's like nah because there is a 90
chance that he's lying or he's there's a
90 chance yes that he's a liar and he's
a cheater absolutely so 90 of men you
think are liars and cheaters to stop
back at that age and I'm saying that
because I know of people in her in her
age group that are not that they were
divorced but they're dating again and
it's just kind of like you know they're
with people who don't add value to their
life like no they don't appreciate them
in confidence and stuff like that and
they just settled but they're unhappy
but that's the point of the graph is
that like they can't get the best people
anymore because they're older um no like
I know someone who's been with someone
for unlike early 50s who's been with
someone for more than 10 years and
they're not happy but they're afraid of
letting go of that because they have to
start all over again but they're not
happy but I think we have a tendency
sorry saying that 90 that you said not
we can't that and I get the situation
and I get sometimes it can be that
trauma stays there but you can't then
base every man off of people that you
know and I think we have a tendency of
doing that in terms of that percentage I
don't think is right because there are
men out there that are willing to start
again there are men out there that have
been cheated on for 10 years by their
their way if there are men out there
that have had to go through trauma with
children to say you know there are men
out there that share the same types of
stories that us women do the the
difference is we're a lot more vocal
about it because we don't have to take
accountability in a sense the way
Society is made you know things to be
where men it's like okay but if she did
cheat on you it's like but what did you
do was you there for her did you do this
for her it's like we're making excuses
why she was cheating on him but if we
say oh a man was cheating on us it's
like oh he had that right yeah I mean
and the other thing is we don't talk
about women's part to playing cheating
I'm not I don't know your story
personally but one out of four marriages
is sexless one out of four so if you're
not sleeping with your husband you're
surprised someone else is yeah exactly
it's not even some men just love
cheating like no some you're right just
some do but it's a small percentage of
men that can cheat most most men one out
of three men under 30 are either sexless
or virgins
it's because we're all going for a small
percentage of men look it do you guys do
you guys think this room are we top ten
percent of women
in the world out of every 10 women top
10 as a group
no looks I'll put myself there don't
mind me today hello yeah I think you're
in the top she could look like a movie
star in a minute do you think you're
you're top ten percent I just said that
yeah no no you're not that's your
opinion I mean I'm not trying to be here
and Brianna came from the island next to
me okay murder without money come on
let's just not no money yeah look at
Rihanna at eight come on uh-huh I'm not
I'm not saying you're bad looking but
I'm not taking it as that Rihanna you
think you're at the same level as
Rihanna yeah call me delusional like
that website but I do
literally what what makes a woman what
what makes you value Rihanna
um in thin I mean I mean I wouldn't say
I wouldn't say she's a 10
um now because she's a bit older but I
would say when she was 22 I would put
her at a nine or ten um because she was
young
um she was thin she was tall she looked
like a model very symmetrical face yeah
I think it's wonderful that you feel
like that about yourself and I think
every woman should feel like that yeah
absolutely but when we do look at it
objectively it's like would it be all of
us sat here or would it be Margot Robbie
and Rihanna and you know what I mean I
think they're like
well have 10 outcomes so you either have
modeling contracts or nines nines and
tenses so we're going by size basically
because everything has to do with size
modeling contract size
who even like we're over complicating it
guys like just who get the most
attention by men if you're walking down
the street
and I mean like in terms of attention
like oh okay like I'd want to take her
home like she's wifey material not just
oh she's got a big fake butt yeah
that's what she's talking about but then
we talk about okay I get you but we talk
about size and then you're like size and
big butt you get it like no but we're
just talking about like attractive just
yeah just looks not personality you know
what else you could bring to the table
Yeah be in the table like actually just
pure looks like what made the final
attract top 10 percent so is that the
only thing that men look for in women
that's what it starts with
who's asking about look sir yeah
yeah look for this particular question
no I understand I just I assumed that
the point you're making was like the a
lower percentage of women are going for
the top 10 men and so do we think we're
the top 10 women but then that's
obviously basing it on the fact that men
are only looking at looks and not the
other things that men do look at other
things but it starts with looks you have
to be over a certain threshold for Matt
yeah see
we all come from different backgrounds
and cultures so where I come from I'm
valued highly as a woman as a black
woman it's only when we integrate
ourselves like for example I use my
example of coming to England where
there's a whole bunch of different
aspects on what men think is beautiful I
always remember when I went to a reggae
concert and
um there's this guy he balanced into me
a Rasta and he was like sorry empress
and it I was like oh shoot like I was
like why did that make me feel
like really respected and I was like
I've forgotten that that's what I grew
up with it's only when I come here that
it's you know there's a sort of
disrespect in how women are greeted in
the Caribbean you're greeted like
Empress Queen you know and it's not just
words they value you so when I come here
and I have to look at Beauty stands and
size and other than that there's no
brain it's a western half of these women
who are how long were you there till how
old
um high school so I was there until 17
18. 18. so that's like yeah so when I
come over here and then you have
different cultures who tell you what
beauty standards are and like what you
should accept that's just here and let
me tell you England has a lot of
influence you have Instagram I do okay
nines and tens get nines and tens
outcomes on Instagram they could be in
Eastern Europe or Russia but the the
rich man will find them what are they
showing though to get that attention I I
look at sometimes it's sexual you know
sometimes it's that but but beautiful
come on a girl that looks like Margot
Robbie I don't even know what that is if
she just showed um there's another one
Rihanna at 22. they would find her yeah
yeah they were in London absolutely but
look at the ages that we're comparing
their beauty and we're speaking about
them now we're saying Rihanna when she
was in her 20s but Rihanna's like but
this I think she's 36. yeah but yeah
that's where you're going to go go off
the graph yeah okay so I find it more
attractive she was a nine at 22. yeah I
don't know so she's like a six seven
seven it's because she's got a kid now
that she's devalued yeah they say that
you know yeah to Matt to men um a kid
subtracts two points so if you're an
eight and you have a kid each kid is two
points
but then also Society tells us that as
women because of like how men mature
that we need to go for older guys yeah
and so it's the sort of thing where half
half the people I know they want a guy
like 10 years is
they can start at 10 years older and so
it's just kind of like and it's not
maybe financially they're more stable
but in terms of how they get treated yes
probably a little bit better because
they've had that life where they've had
kids so there's no pressure for them to
have kids or there's more of a financial
stability they probably own a house by
then you know but
there's different things you know but I
think it's about like the Western
Community though because I think what
you're going to look for I mean I'm
Jamaican like what you're going to look
for in the Caribbean is different to
what the stats would be like over here
you know we're part of like a Western
Community in terms of men are like I
don't think yeah I disagree with that um
I think I think beauty is just crazy I
know what you mean like yes we do
slightly you know you do yeah there's a
slight difference but I think a very
good looking girl I'm saying like men
and women though I'm saying like for
example like what I'm saying is we're
not being in terms of what you're saying
in terms of beauty and stuff I'm saying
like I would disagree with you in terms
of we're not being realistic on like you
said what I'm what a man would actually
gravitate to if that's be or highly
gravitate to because like the 20 of men
I mean in that 20 I don't think much of
them are going to be tubby do you know
what I mean I think they're going to be
quite athletic or masculine in that way
do you know what I mean so I'm saying in
terms of being realistic I agree with
you in a sense where there's a certain
type of woman that men would gravitate
to more right my only point was that
everyone here who had the highest
percentage 20 percent
like when we did the delusion calculator
what was it the who had the highest
percentages and you picked what was it
20 yes 15. yeah 15 and it came up to
13.8 okay yeah 13 that so out of us
we're all we're all competing for up to
13 of guys would you say that you're in
the top 10 women there because what
you've disc what you've described in the
podcast is like what makes an attractive
woman is like slim you're slim you've
got a symmetrical face you have feminine
features and you've got long hair you
wear dresses like so what makes you not
that 10
um
I I think I'm cute but I don't I don't
think I'm the top 10 of facial symmetry
um I think I could probably lose a
little weight you know um I think you
could I've seen you'll cook things you
have lost weight you look great thank
you thank you thank you I did see your
Chef things on on Twitter yeah no um
I've lost a bit of weight but no I mean
I think it'd be quite delusional to say
I'm in the top temper like if I'm
looking at Margot Robbie and Rihanna at
22. do I think that I compete with them
and we're going to be talking to the
same men no no I I and I don't think
that's a bad thing to say that most
people are average I don't think there's
anything wrong with just being an
average person but do you want the talk
do you want a mat as a six foot woman do
you want a man taller than you do you do
you I do ideally but um I don't mind if
they're a bit shorter that you settle
um I wouldn't I wouldn't say subtle um I
think that settling implies that like
you somehow don't deserve what you get I
think you always deserve what you get
like I think if you deserve if if you
qualify for the top 10 percent of men
you'll get them and if you haven't got
them you don't qualify I think you can
get info thank you I appreciate that a
lot of men don't even want a 10 anyway
we want like a nice seven or eight like
a really good looking girl but not super
arrogant itself can see in all the
things that tend to come with the most
attractive girl so there's no shame in
not being in the top ten percent or
being a ten like I don't understand why
it has to be like a little girl yeah
he's like no you're still a great person
you're still a good looking girl it's
fine you don't have to be a 10 you can
feel a ten but it doesn't mean like you
know I agree with you but it's I think
and I completely understand but it's
like who are you to tell someone they're
not attend like not not not not being
disrespectful not in that but I'm just
in conversation like
it's all raised on what we were told is
a 10. especially in today's beauty
standards you know so we can't be picky
and choosy because people are who they
are in terms of tens five six I expect
to live in reality though like I think
like a lot of times as women like we
just live in delusion and we're never
told the truth ever and I I think it's
it's quite delusional to to think that
I'm on the same level as Rihanna I think
that's delusional well I'm told the
truth I've grown on that so yeah I'd say
I'm definitely told the truth like if
I'm like I'm a dancer if I do a dance my
dad's gonna tell me I need to go on
train I mean if I'm putting on a bit of
weight they're gonna tell me to go get
in that gym girl so I've always been
told the truth I think that's why I just
reality is reality you can't fight it in
it my mom tells me the truth all the
time like she but it's the way she does
it but she tells me the truth all the
time so
but we just have to this isn't another
topic but beauty standards like what who
are we to say beauty is this you know
like I agree if you if you're with your
woman and you choose your woman right to
you she's a 10. so other people she's
not right to you men just lie
do men lie yes women men like to get
books no but if you have your woman
would you I don't I I don't lie about
men do you lie so you don't lie but your
man I don't lie because I you know if if
I was gonna go out to go I find her
attractive yeah I mean yeah but a lot of
men do lie and try to say the sweetest
thing when you said Jamaican I thought
bloody oh you're gonna say Ireland boys
Ireland boys are the most promiscuous
let's be honest they're saying that
Queen
they love a pillow talking ladies
yeah they do I don't even think like I
feel like beauty standards they're just
hot and not hot that's my opinion I
don't think I think most men
will look at every every race and just
hot or not hot
yeah yeah you're not then I agree I've
never worried about that then like my
my partner is probably in the top
percentage of and that he earns well he
buys me nice bags he takes me nice
places he's six foot three
but obviously I didn't know what he
looked like before I met him but like
I've never struggled and like I'm
overweight like I'm not the best looking
one in the world Margo Robbie could
absolutely take me in a beauty pageant
100 times good for you but like I've
never struggled with that I think
there's so much more to it it's about
like your circles and who you're around
and but you're like what are you doing
you're not married no I don't want to be
right now but I'm saying the outcome is
marriage that most women are looking for
yeah so you haven't really won until
you're married that's an interesting way
to look at relationships though I mean I
would just okay do you do you think that
marriage is above a relationship like
yeah it's more committed but I do I
don't want that commitment right now
okay and that's fine no no problem
yeah I don't think it is though that's
but I you don't think you'd have an
easier time if you were thinner
I think that I've always done so I've
been thin and I've always done well I
did better in entertainment when I was
thinner 100 yeah because I was more
attractive and so I got more actually so
if they pulled the top 10 20 of men and
they took a picture of you heavier and
thinner which one would they pick
typically thinner but that doesn't mean
that it's held me back I'm not saying
you can't it can't happen but I think I
just haven't struggled and what I'm
trying to add well I mean you're a
pretty girl you know I mean yeah I mean
I'm not so I'm I'm not saying that you
can't have that outcome I just think if
we're going on a balance of
probabilities you have a modeling
contract right yeah so that means at
least facial you're above average yeah
well plus size model correct and so like
that worked out for you because you're a
pretty girl but most women are average
most people are not above average
yeah so of course you're going to
struggle less
you disagree with that no I no
moving on
um would you are you with an overweight
guy no no okay would you would you be
with one yeah before okay so you got no
problem